hello this is Jason with the local
locksmith company today we're doing a
2019 Chevy
Silverado it's add a key here's the
customer's original key you can hear the
do lock
cycle here's the key we're
adding
nothing so for this process you're going
to need
internet you're going to need a good uh
Wi-Fi signal because uh you need
internet to do this
key and uh a good key and a good
programmer we're using the altel
im508
and we're going to
connect and we're going to Auto detect
the the
system so it's Auto detecting right now
and it's to tell us what uh what vehicle
this is so it's going to be Chevy
America okay and the
VIN
okay pulls the correct VIN check the uh
battery in it the batter's got
uh good
juice we always want to make sure we
look at the battery so it's a 2019
Silverado we're going to head yes
Silverado
1500 17 to
20 smart
key and we're going to go to hot
function we're going to add smart key
guided for this process it's going to
have to read the pen so we're going to
hit start reading the pen once it reads
the pen I'll get back with you I'm going
to pause you for a second let it read
the pen and I'll be
back okay it's read the pin and now it's
ask me do I want to start the key
learning process I hit yes I want to
start the key learning process I got to
put this down because it may show the
pin number again so it says press the
stop start button
once so we're going to press it
once okay
okay so it's telling you asking you put
the uh the key in the slot the
programming slot on this
2019 Chevy Silverado the key programming
slot is right here if it has bucket
seats okay if it has bucket seats it
goes between these two cup holders in
that little square slot if it didn't
have bucket
seats and it had a bench seat it would
go in the back of here there'd be a slot
right in here here
somewhere but since this has bucket
seats it goes right here here's the slot
for a
2019 Chevy Silverado programming slot
this slot also is helpful if the battery
in your key fob goes dead and you can't
start your car you put your key fob
right here and then you hit the start
button okay so we're going to hit okay
we're going to hold the camera down
because I think it's going to show me
the pen it did we're going to hit okay
we're going to hit okay again it shows
the pen a couple times so it says switch
the ignition off which it is
off check in the
network it says wait 5
Seconds okay it's now it's a 12 minute
wait okay for this 12 minute wait I am
going to put you on pause we'll put you
on pause and we'll come back when the 12
minutes is
up however this would be a good time now
to say if you like this video hit like
if you want to see more hit subscribe
and if you want to visit our website go
to myne locks.com that's for the local
locksmith company in down river Michigan
let we're in Trenton Michigan we cover
the entire Down River Michigan and
Monroe Michigan uh area for uh
automotive locksmith services I'll put
you on hold and then we'll come back as
soon as the 12 minute weight is up come
back in a minute all right it's back
on so we're going to look at the uh Dash
look at the dash it says press the stop
start button once okay if you look at
the dash here and it says number of
ready for remote number
three right there I'm going to push the
stop start button
once and hit
okay it didn't work let's see what's
going on maybe I got it in the wrong
spot well we'll go through and we'll
just double check everything says it's
ready for remote 3 so it's configuring
the
system it didn't work but we're going to
check
it so it's going through the current key
is complete matching you want to match
the next one no because we're done
matching Keys switch the ignition
off okay switched it off press the stop
start run for 12 seconds
this does the counting for
us I didn't think it took that key I
know it
didn't so we're going to find out
though so release the stop start button
hit
okay configuring the system please wait
Seconds long press the stop start button
till the ignition turns on so we're
going to long press it and wait for the
dash to come on so not that light but
the big ones them ones so them lights
come
on so we're just paying attention to
what it's telling us to
do switch the ignition
off so it's off press and hold the brake
and the stop start button and wait and
wait for the engine well the problem is
I have this other key in here so I'm
going to take this key
out and we're going to go just like this
and we're going to press and hold the
brake so it says no remote detected so I
know it didn't
work I knew it didn't work so this is a
good problem to have so we'll let it go
through it what it
says we're going to try this again
so we have to go through and it didn't
program so we have to go through it and
we have to figure out why it didn't
program there could be many reasons why
it could be a bad key it could have been
St sit in the wrong
spot but I looked in the owner's manual
and that's exactly where the owner's
manual tells you to put the new
key so we're just waiting for it right
now to uh to get back out of this mode
so once it gets out of this mode I'll be
back all right now it says it
failed I'll take a look it's good to
fail I mean it's not good to fail really
but we're going to start over and do
this again so we're going to hit
start yes we want to we want to start
the key learning process yes
press the stop star button
once
okay okay it's in the slot where it says
it's supposed to go oh there's the PIN
code all right switch the ignition
off I believe it is off just checking
the network it's waiting 5
Seconds to configure the
system configuring the system could take
12 minutes so we got to go through this
again so we're going to try it again we
don't usually fail but we did this time
so this is a good lesson I guess got to
try
again all right we're back now and
here's a couple of things that I've done
if you
look I've got the fourways on I don't
normally put the fourways on and I've
also moved the key from this Center here
to the cup holder and it says ready for
remote
three right
there so it says to push the start start
button stop start button
once didn't
work so we're going to try to find where
this is at
all right I don't see any other place in
this vehicle or we could program a a
key
but let's
see ready for remote
I'll try that
one all
right I'm going to pause it it's ready
for
remote all right hang on one
second all right so
no problems that we can't resolve so I'm
going to turn it back and show you so so
we're still on remote
3 from what I understand about this
vehicle now
is the programming
slot is underneath of this which you
lift up this is the
console I don't know how to close it but
under here's this another
console and in that counil in the corner
is a pocket and this is where you put
your key if the battery goes dead and to
program the button so now we're going to
go back up here and we're going to push
the stop start button one
time and it changes to remote 4 and I
hit okay here found it and I hit okay on
here and we go through this configuring
the system
okay so we're configuring the system
we're going to wait 10
seconds 9 10 and then we're going to the
current complete key is complete and
matching do you want to match the next
key no just need switch the ignition off
one button should push it off so it's
off press the stop start button for 12
seconds so we're it'll count for us so
we're pressing in the button it's
counting for
us we're still on remote four see the
remote four down
there release the stop start
button hit
okay now we're going to configure the
system for 5 seconds and I'm pretty sure
we're going to long press it next so
we're going to do the long press now we
hold it on we long press the button we
wait for the back dash lights to come on
all of them right there
okay release
it switch the ignition
off ignition is off put your foot on the
brake pedal and press the stop start
button to start the engine and wait for
seconds so the truck
started it's configuring the system for
seconds switch the ignition off
all right stop the engine open and
closes the driver's door remove the
smart key press the lock and unlock
button on both key on the on the key to
make sure you hear the Lo door locks go
off
okay that should be is there another key
to be synchronized no number of keys
match now there's three
matched okay that's
it succeeded
all right so in the owner's manual it
said the pocket was
here
which wasn't here so it said it was
here I don't even know how to pull this
up oh right here maybe this is it right
so it said it
was it was right
here or it said it would be here however
Maybe in the
book it should have
said you have to lift
this maybe I make I misunderstood the
picture to mean the pocket is here so
this is where you put your key if the
battery goes dead in your key fob to
start your car you put your key fob in
there and then you hit the start button
all right well this was a long video
longer than I
anticipated um appreciate you watching
if you liked it I mean we got we had a
problem we solved it we got through it
um hit like if you have any questions or
you want to make a comment drop them in
the comment section if you want to see
more subscribe to my channel and thanks
for watching and visit myw locks.com
that's my website thanks